you probably wouldn't trust a robot to
babysit your kids or write you a
prescription so why should you trust one
to manage your money picking individual
Investments to build out a portfolio can
be extremely intimidating what normal
person wants to make sense of endless
graphs and charts that's where Robo
advisors can come in originally
introduced in 2008 they've been steadily
gaining popularity and now manage over
one trillion dollars of investor assets
despite the name there are no robots
involved the robo refers to an algorithm
that automatically allocates and manages
a low-cost Investment Portfolio based on
your goals these are tools that
Financial Pros have had access to for
decades and are now available to anyone
it's a great place for beginners and
experts alike to get their money working
for them without the headache of
interpreting graphs or hours of research